[Music]
my family has fallen apart and my life
has pretty much blown up here in the
last couple of weeks and i'm trying to
get some guidance on where to go from
here i screwed everything up and i don't
know what to do but before you do
anything else before you go down the
rabbit hole what do i do you have to sit
in it for a second and grieve
[Music]
what up what up what up this is john
with the dr john delony show and hey i
was just doing an interview and somebody
told me like dude you yell all the time
and i was like no i don't and i was like
oh my gosh i do
so
for everybody
i i don't know i'm a quiet guy
am i a quiet guy you you have this voice
you go into when you're talking real
seriously you're like really really
quiet and then you'll just yell so it's
very dynamic dynamic that was a nice way
of saying i love you and you're a lot
thank you for that james we should get
married so for everybody else i'm going
to redo the show like this
hey everybody welcome to the dr john
dolone show i'm glad that you're here
and for those of you who i'm a lot for
i hope this is a better intro for you
for the rest of you you can go ahead and
put it back on 1x because i'll go back
to speaking too fast somebody sent me a
case of energy drinks today
and i'd never
tried them but i did today i was like i
see what happens and so this may be the
quickest show of all time let's go to
michael in portland oregon what's up
michael
hi john thank you so much for taking my
call it's an honor to speak with you
it's an honor to talk to you my brother
what's up
um my family has fallen apart and my
life is pretty much blown up here in the
last couple of weeks and i'm trying to
get some guidance on where to go from
here
yeah let me know what's up i'm so sorry
what's going on
so
seven years ago i met this lady at work
and we became really good friends for
about two years and she was married to a
man she had been with since she was a
teenager that she had a kid with and
they were in a really unhappy marriage
and against my better judgment i pursued
her and started to date her and three
months after we started dating we got
engaged
i went head over heels i borrowed
fifteen thousand dollars for my mother
to put a down payment on a house
i moved jessica and her son in with me
and we all lived as a family and for the
first like two years things were pretty
good
quick pause quick quick quick pause
and she was still married with a kid
yep okay all right continue
so we we got pregnant and had a
miscarriage we got pregnant had another
miscarriage we did that four times
this time we finally had our son about a
year and a half two years ago and then a
few months later got pregnant again and
had a daughter so now we have three kids
and we're all living in the house
for the last year and a half or so
jessica and i have kind of grown apart
there's been like a disconnection in our
relationship and originally when i
called your show i was going to ask how
to reconnect with her
but in the pit of my stomach i always
had a feeling that something was going
on and i found out that she cheated on
me with somebody that she was working
with
and it destroyed me and
um we had a blowout of course about that
and stuff and
we've decided that we're going to go to
counseling and try to make things work
but she's going to move out and get her
own place
and since we've had that blow out she
barely spends any nights at home
the disconnection is a hundred times
greater than it was before
and i'm just falling apart john and i
don't know what to do
i don't know what to do i i
i screwed everything up and i don't know
what to do so number one thanks for
calling and you're right this is a mess
okay
it's a big mess i've listened to every
episode of your show and i've never
heard somebody with a mess this bad and
i don't know how i went down this road
so far um
you found somebody who would love you
and connection makes us do dumb things
and it gets us in over our head and so
does fantasy and a picture of this could
work and we can figure this out and
someone that looks at us and says i love
you
it changes us right
yeah it does yeah it does um
and so if you've listened to so let me
clarify a couple things one there's been
several episodes that have never aired
and probably never will either i didn't
do a good job or some of the
conversations were really heavy and just
weren't appropriate for the show and so
you're not the you're not your situation
isn't the craziest okay okay
when you were when you're outlining it
for me when you watched this yeah my
eyebrows were touching my my hairline
okay i was like oh oh oh oh let's have
another oh we'll have another kid so yes
you've done a doozy right let's make no
mistake about it i wish i could have
impressed you in a better way john
what's up good man it's all good if you
were here i'd still buy you a beer and
some nachos man we'd hang out so
here's the thing
um i'm gonna be super honest with you
and i know this is a heavy
season of your life okay
okay i really appreciate that um this is
completely full stop over
she's moved on she's done it before
and she's done it to probably her
husband or her person who's still her
husband there's probably somebody in
between you two
and
then there was you and now the same
script has played itself out again
and it's heartbroken breaking and is
grief and it is shame it is all those
things
but before you do anything else before
you go down the rabbit hole what do i do
all this
you have to sit in it for a second and
grieve
you got in over your head with somebody
who
told you something and they weren't
honest with you
and they never fully went all in on you
and for some reason there's some story
in your life that told you if i just do
the next right thing that's then
somebody will love me and then the next
person will love me
and you've been trying to do the next
right thing for a long long time
for my whole life and it's never worked
out because that's not the problem
you're trying to fix an internal hole
with an external external plug and
that's not how it works
and so before any of the healing happens
before any of you what the crap do i do
now happens
there's a sit in it and grieve the sucks
and this hurts and now we've got two
kids that we brought into this
and we have a third kid that's about to
have their life erupt that gets blown up
again
and i participated in this and hey
like just talking to you and for a
couple of minutes
you've known all along this wasn't right
and i'm not talking about like
like any sort of like morality like
somebody else's wife you know what i
mean like you've known something sir
what kept you going
you're right though you're right
that's right but but it's it's haunted
you but the love has
this this this picture around love that
you've been chasing for a long time it
kept you like i'll just go one more step
and one more step one more step tell me
about that journey man because this
didn't happen overnight
what do you mean exactly
like how do you get from man this person
at work is really she's super good
looking she's funny she laughs at my
jokes she does that when i walk in she
puts her hand on my part of my arm and
nobody touches me nobody's touched me in
a long time and it's not sexual but i
like it right she does all these things
and i know there's this big thing like
oh yeah she has a husband and a family
but she says it's on the rocks and i
know that's probably not true but i
can't like i'm just gonna go down this
road like
and all sudden you wake up and you get
two kids like what tell me about that
journey man what happened
i i don't know everything just seemed to
happen so fast you know and i just i
knew it was wrong going in but i just it
felt so perfect it felt so like it just
i felt like she was my soul mate i i
just i was convinced i was just i think
the problem part of the problem was i
was single for like 10 years before she
came along that's right i didn't date
anybody for like 10 years i had other
rough relationships that didn't end well
and
i've been alone for a long time and i
think this like you said having somebody
give me that kind of attention that i
hadn't had in so long maybe i
misconstrued what i thought was love
wasn't really love i don't think that as
much as um
you know if if i spent a few hours with
her
she
she probably didn't love who she had
become in her other relationship and you
made her feel alive you made her feel
funny you do you smile to her in a
different way whatever it was and i
wouldn't say that she didn't love you i
wouldn't i think that would be a false
mischaracterization that would be me
being mean i don't think that i don't
think you're crazy
i think you were so enamored by the
fantasy of the family and she's
beautiful and she chose you after all
these years of being lonely that you
were willing to sacrifice your values
you're willing to sacrifice you knew it
was going to end in ash i mean we know
that and it just it just sits in the
back of our head and gnaws slowly at us
and for most of us when we are in
situations like that
we know it's going to end poorly
we try to outrun that that clawing that
fire that's burning through the back of
our brains and
it causes us to suffocate the thing that
we're trying to protect right it causes
us to hold a little too tight and we get
a little too crazy about it we get a
little too intense and then that
person's
they're on to the next right
yeah yeah that's exactly what happened
too
so here we find herself
and here imagine
like you and i are sitting on a curb man
and i'm lighting your cigarette with you
and the neighborhood behind us is on
fire right so i'm sitting here with you
here we find herself
step one is to sit down and grieve this
it just sucks it hurts
you've been lonely for a long time and
now you're staring at it again
and now i've got these kids that are in
the house like all the time and like
it's hard to like it's hard to be a good
dad because i'm just so upset that i've
let them down yeah
you know yeah i get that i don't deserve
that's not their fault it's my fault and
i just like i don't know how to get past
that i just keep beating myself up
because
i i've wrecked them too
i feel like i've wrecked them too and i
know i haven't they're two in one but
still i have to appoint because they're
not going to have that fantasy yeah and
so
you got to put a period at the end of
that fantasy and then you have to ask
the scariest hardest question that any
of us have to ask
and you're not the only one brother you
have to get in a long line for this
question
what am i going to do next
and you have no idea i'm telling you
right now you have an opportunity to
stand up and be the greatest father
these two little ones have could have
ever known
and their mom has chosen to step out
great i'm not going to talk bad about
mom
mom's gonna go do her own thing
and we were never married in the first
place and so i'm gonna have to get
attorney and figure out custody stuff
and i'm gonna fight like hell from my
two little kids
and
i'm gonna work real hard to make this a
stable home and to make sure we've got
stable care and i'm gonna go about my
life raising these two little ones
because i love them and for the first
time in my life
i'm gonna go talk to somebody
because i don't have an appointment
scheduled on thursday atta boy man that
see
you you've helped me so much i didn't do
anything
i run my mouth on a podcast you're the
one that looked at those two little kids
and said enough's enough's enough i
gotta i gotta be different i gotta heal
so i can do this thing differently i
really wanna be a good dad john that's
all i've ever wanted my dad walked out
on us and i never had a dad and all i
told myself my whole life was like if i
ever have kids i'm never going to do
what my dad did i'm going to be there
all the time for everything and i am now
and she's gone all the time she's gone
for nights at a time and she doesn't
spend the time with them like she should
yeah so i'm never gonna be like that i'm
always gonna be there i'll ask you that
i want you to state it boldly are you
ever gonna walk out on these kids
absolutely not then listen to me listen
to me
you are the man who stops the forest
fire of trauma raging through your
family because of what your dad did
stops at you
is this how we would have drawn it up
that you had two kids with a married
woman no that's not how we drew it up
but here's where we are
so tomorrow starts today
i will not leave period is it going to
be tough on these kids because their
mom's going to be in and out of their
yep i will not leave i will be here and
i will get down on all fours and i will
learn to laugh and i don't know how to
mix formula i'm gonna figure it out
i don't know how
how many diapers a day i'm gonna figure
it out
it's about 15 john
yeah they're like machines man they keep
coming and coming and coming now if you
were and i had been friends for 20 or 30
years and you were at my house telling
me this you know i'd be like making fun
of you i'd be all over you i'm not doing
that to you i i'm sitting with you right
now okay cause this sucks and you know
and me beating you up is there's no
reason for that you're in it now
where i'm gonna stay on you is this
you cannot move forward chasing anymore
you gotta stop and own what happened you
got to own the stories you got to own
the fact that your dad left you and
you've been chasing for somebody to look
you've been trying to solve what is
wrong with me
for a long time
is it possible that maybe there's not
something wrong with me there's a
hundred percent not something wrong with
you you've done stupid things there's
nothing wrong with you
your dad left because something was
wrong with him
not you
and my fiance is leaving because there's
something wrong with her
she's searching for something brother
that has nothing to do with you
okay she's trying to feel alive
and she has put alive
she has chosen that as a as a feeling
she's chosen that as a destination as as
in a person and the moment that she
doesn't feel alive she has chosen to not
do things in her life and her
relationships that keep her alive
and allow other people to help keep her
alive she goes to the next
and you know what she's going to find
somebody else that's going to be a shiny
new toy and then she's going to be on it
the next after that
what do i do right now because she's
still living in the house with me and i
have to face this every day
should i be trying to like push her out
of the house or sh
you know one of my friends said change
the locks and put her crap outside i'm
like i'm not doing that to the mother of
my children at the end of the day she's
always the mother of my children i'm
never going to treat her like that so i
don't know what she does
my friend my friend dave gave me this
quote and i like it
and you're it's not technically your
situation but it's close enough
the moment you
somebody files for divorce
it becomes a business transaction
with a period at the end and i treat all
of my business partners with respect i
tip well i pay on time i take care of
people and if i screw something up i say
i'm sorry so that's not a recipe to be a
jerk or to be an idiot or to be
disrespectful
but it's about it's a transaction now
and business transactions start with
hard conversations and so
next up first thing you're going to do
is you're going to call an attorney and
you're going to let them know what
happened
and that's going to be expensive and
that's just the season you're in okay
the second thing you're going to do is
you're going to tell your wife hey we i
mean your girlfriend we need to have a
conversation about future
and you tell her i know this is over now
let's call it
i would like full custody of these two
kids if that's what you want
and that's what i want
i would like full custody of these kids
i'm willing to take on the burden of
this stuff i will sign it away and or if
you will sign
the pieces of paper i've already went
and met with a lawyer
and um i will not be in a relationship
where you're dating where you're married
to one
living with me and dating a third i draw
the line there and it's time for me to
have some relational boundaries because
i'm modeling what love looks like to a
two-year-old and a one-year-old
i'm modeling what love and wellness and
wholeness and relationship look like to
a two-year-old and a one-year-old and
this isn't the model i'm gonna give them
okay and by the way
you
michael are worth more than this
doesn't feel like it sometimes i know i
know i know
but you are
okay do you believe me
no
that's fine i don't lie so
you can uh i exaggerate the size of the
fish i catch usually like that's for
real but i don't lie
and you're worth more than this
okay and if you will put the work in
and heal
you'll find somebody who loves you
and those two little knuckleheads
all of you
even the weird
gnarly parts even the wonky parts even
the parts where she's like
wait what you had to what and you're
like i know i know i know
i'm as wonky as they come hey brother
trust me people invite me into their
closets for a living it's what i do
we're all wonky
but you're worth being well my brother
i'm so proud of you for making the call
moving forward it's about three things
number one you protect those kids
come hell or high water you protect
those kids number two
you reach out and you start the healing
process period
number three you start learning in short
i mean you you run away from real short
for this you got to develop new
boundaries now
here's what i will tolerate here's what
i will not tolerate and when your
girlfriend kicks and screams and yells
and oh my gosh i can't believe you
you're judging me after all
i was wrong
and i'm doing things differently now
starting now
and the fourth and final thing is you
got to get a couple of buddies in your
area that are going to walk alongside
you that will show up at 2 a.m when
you're pulling your hair out because you
don't know how to stop a two-year-old
and a one-year-old from crying at the
same time
somebody will come over and help you
babysit somebody that will bring chips
and queso over and help rock one kid
while you're changing the other like you
need a couple of guys
no men and women don't care people show
up and be there for you because you're
going to need other people in this
season of your life
okay
thank you for being brave thank you for
calling tomorrow starts right
now you're worth it brother make the
call
[Music]
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and then
i'll try to upsell you a bunch of
nonsense that's going to hurt you down
the road and most importantly when
you're making this big life change you
can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back
listen if you're about to buy a home and
make a big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan
200. this is a paid advertisement in mls
id 1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we're back let's go to laney
in sacramento what's up laney
hey dr john how you doing partying dude
what are you up to
um i'm at home with two sick kids
so we're we're partying over here too
man
dude does your house smell like saltine
crackers and the price is right and
sprite
dude all my windows are open and it
smells like straight vomit and sweat in
here ah
that
gross
like james's car but go ahead hey so
what's up
um well i wanted to call and i'm not
going to give you a ton of back
information up front because i know
you'll kind of dig and get what you need
out but basically my question is just
how do i become the solution to the
problem of
not liking my kids like i love them to
death but i'm finding myself in a place
where i'm
not liking them
not like sometimes but like majority of
the time um that's a great question hey
thank you for
thank you for having the courage to say
that out loud most parents won't say
that because then the shame cycle just
starts right and there were people
looking at them weird so it totally
feels like a taboo subject like even
bringing it up i'm just like am i the
only one that is feeling this because
this is
tough and it sucks
yeah dude how old are your kids
uh my daughter is six and a half and my
son is four and a half oh gosh
yeah you're right in it man
you are gonna think of it you're right
in it so
um
when did you start not liking them
probably
i started noticing it probably about
a year or two ago
um and just kind of dismissed it with oh
well you know i didn't have that
immediate connection with them after
they were born i had postpartum
depression really bad after both of them
and so i just kind of brushed it off
with you know just having those feelings
and that they'll come and go and i'm
just probably irritated because i'm
juggling so many different things
but then i started noticing that i'm
like i talk to them like crap sometimes
like i'll do the same thing my mom did
and just yell at them and then after i
yell at them i'll just like look in the
mirror and just be so disgusted with
myself like how can you say that to your
kids
most of the most of the time i find that
when i am struggling with liking my kids
i always love them
when i talk to people who are struggling
with liking their kids
they don't like their body's response to
their children
yeah
if you've gone through postpartum and it
was heavy
i'm speculating here i don't have any
research studies but this is just me
having
countless conversations with women
who've experienced this um
your body has now put a pin in the story
that that kid equals hurt
that kid equals pain that kid equals
fill in the blank
and every time that kid comes into your
presence it starts up a cycle
that your body's trying to protect you
from
and there's nothing worse than your body
reacting to holding your freaking baby
right
right and then you think something's
wrong with you and then the loser like
there's just no connection no emotion
and that's your body trying to protect
you
from a story that was real at one point
at one point postpartum depression was
scary as all get out wouldn't it
yeah yeah it was terrifying
and your body's like i remember that
story and
they were involved
yeah and every scream every everything
rages you up and then you put that on
top of the story you're still carrying
around with you about what you're worth
because of your mom what'd she do to you
um my mom
my mom experienced a lot of hurt in her
life
stop don't go apologizing for her yet
she's a grown-up
what's your mom do to you
she was a single mom of three kids who
stop apologizing for your mom
what'd your mom do she
she worked all the time so she was never
there
sorry she was never there
and when she was it was constant
fighting and i was never good enough
i never did anything right
um so i just always felt very worthless
and i know she didn't mean it that way
but
that's what it made me feel as a kid
and um
she just yelled all the time and it
finally got to a point where i started
sneaking out the house and going and
hanging out with friends that i knew i
shouldn't be hanging out with because i
just simply didn't want to be around her
i didn't want to be in her presence
and i'm starting to
sorry
i'm starting to notice my six-year-old
feel the same way towards me
and it sucks to see this cycle repeat
yeah
and so the great terry reel
the great therapist terry reel says
family trauma is like a forest fire that
rages through
family history until somebody has the
courage to turn and face it and say no
more
and you my sister lainey you're going to
get burned in the process it's going to
hurt
and
those kids of yours and their kids and
their kids after them
will live differently because you chose
and said no more
and yes six and a half year olds can be
wildly annoying they make up crap they
get into stuff they're testing every
boundary and every thought and ev right
there
they're just little button button
pushers because they're trying to figure
out how the world works
and
gosh it could be so annoying so annoying
right yeah like they just bring out the
worst sides of me and like hold on hold
on hold on hold on hold on hold on
i wanna stop that okay
you choose to let part of you emerge
when they push certain buttons you're in
control they're not
and i don't feel like i'm in control i
know i feel like
i just reacted like i know the right
answer in my head but when the situation
arises it's just like
all of my anger and rage is just invoked
and then it's just like i'm constantly
disappointed in my reactions and
um just feeling like i'm continuing this
unintentionally
repeating the cycle even though that's
the one thing i don't want to do that's
right
because you're trying to
instead of slowing down and putting on a
seat belt you're trying to stop the car
crash after the skid's already happening
okay
this stuff gets changed way way way
upstream
and it starts with you
letting seven-year-old laney know
that your mom messed up
she missed out on a pretty awesome
little girl
she missed out on a girl who was funny
and silly
and had lots of energy
and was smart
she missed all of it
through her exhaustion and her rage and
her anger and her dismissiveness
and at some point you got to go back and
let little laney go because right now
laney is defending you and lainey's
running the show little ladies running
the show that's why you act like a
seven-year-old when you respond to your
kids you scream you yell you throw
things and you feel bad about it and
then you repeat
yeah okay
that's a that's a you've probably heard
this and it sounds all woo-woo that's
your inner child saying oh i remember
this i'll come to defense because i've
been defending laney her whole life
because i had to because mom wasn't
there to do it
and you have to look in the mirror and
say adult laney is worth loving
these two kids
did good by me
they're lucky to have me as a mom and
i'm gonna backfill that identity with
new actions and i'm gonna backfill that
identity with new thoughts and i'm gonna
learn new ways this is a tools issue not
a character issue okay
okay you don't have the tools in your
bag to not yell
you don't have another you don't have
another thing to do that's just how you
solve problems
yeah
like we have we have my dad come over on
tuesday nights for taco tuesday and
he'll get to see you know obviously
they're acting out in their attitudes
and my dad was never there for me so i
just kind of take everything he says
with a grain of salt not being
disrespectful or anything but it's like
you can't really give fatherly advice
when you weren't a father
um
and his answer to everything is oh put
them in their room
whoop their butt and i'm like i work at
a mental health counseling agency and
have for the last eight years and i've
learned a lot about positive parenting
and the emotional damage that occurs
with that kind of reactions to their
behavior and his thing is well they'll
learn real quick won't they i'm like
yeah but they'll learn to fear me not
respect me okay
every time you invite your dad over your
body recognizes that bear
and it starts into fight or flight and
you are unable to have good
relationships or interactions with him
because your body's not present with you
it's in defense because that guy was
supposed to have shown up
and that guy was supposed to have loved
you as a daughter and have held you
accountable and hugged you
so tight you couldn't breathe
and he should have stepped between you
and your mom when she was yelling and
screaming he shouldn't have left you
you hear what i'm saying
yeah
and so at some point soon taco tuesdays
need to come to an end
because you think you're doing right by
everything and you're just perpetuating
a fantasy that is keeping your body
fully limbic that is putting those girls
in an unsafe situation and giving access
to this guy who doesn't deserve access
to your family right now because you're
not whole and well yet
i've heard you say before
that it's important to give 30 second
hugs and so um like a week or two ago i
gave i gave both my kids hugs when i
dropped them off at school
and
my daughter just she didn't even lift
her arms up she didn't hug me back and
there was no reason for it we didn't
fight that morning or anything but like
when i let go over i just looked at her
and i was like oh so mommy doesn't get a
hug like no i love you don't have a good
day no nothing and she just looked at me
shook her head with this just look of
anger and disgust and like almost pure
hatred towards me
and
it reminded me of the exact same way i
felt as a 16 year old like her face
looked like me at 16. hey lainey lainey
i want her to
she's six
she's six
you know what's going on in the mind of
a six-year-old
nobody knows
one of the things i work really hard and
it's real hard cause i have a
six-year-old little girl too
who sometimes will hug me so tight i
can't breathe and it fills my soul
and then other times i say come give me
a hug i gotta go to work and she's like
no thank you
and my first thought is
because you suck at being a dad because
you're always gone cause you're always
lecturing all your kids about screens
and blah blah running your mouth and
they don't think your fart jokes are
funny
and then i have to stop myself and go no
she's six
i am a good dad
and i'm not gonna judge every
interaction as though it's the end of
all time that this is it or that's it
and otherwise i'm not gonna do that
i'm not gonna give my daughter the
burden of having to carry my emotional
weight
i'm going to say you don't have to hug
me but i'm going to hug you because i
love you
and then i'm going to leave
i'm going to teach her
you don't get to set my mom or dad's
like emotional state you're not that
powerful you're six you're little bitty
i'm a grown-up i set my emotional state
and my feelings i make choices about my
behavior you don't have that power
and only then will a kid be able to drop
their shoulders and feel safe
and hug recklessly
and it seems counterintuitive
but your daughter is carrying the weight
of the house the way you had to carry
the weight of the house and it's time to
take that weight off of her shoulders
and take it back
and by the way
laney you're strong
you've been carrying heavy stuff for a
long time
it's just finally breaking it is it is
and then like just to add
just to add more to the situation um my
daughter was about three and a half or
four years old when we had her in a
in-home daycare that was through a
family friend
and a situation happened when she was
four and one of the older kids that was
there he was like seven or eight
they were in the living room while the
daycare person was making lunch and they
were playing house and he told
all the kids that were there there was
like four or five of them that in order
to be married and play house that you
know the girl has to pull her pants down
and he has to put his wiener on her butt
so that happened when she was four
and ever since then she has been
way way way overly curious
she'll try to walk in on her brother in
the bathroom she'll try to walk in on
her dad in the bathroom
and now it's it's spilled over into
school stuff and she um she's asking
kids at school if she can see their junk
and it has gotten to a point where the
principal and i have had to sit down and
basically say like either she gets into
counseling or she can't come back here
because now
initial incident happened did you take
her in
immediately
no i did it okay that today
two things there's not an inappropriate
curiosity for kids when it comes to
their body parts and
like that should be an open conversation
and
your child was sexually assaulted
okay and that's scary to say it like
that you've got to treat it as such
and i know that when things happen in
our own homes
that it it's it can be so disorienting
that it's hard to put labels like that
on things that happen in our home
and especially it was just another young
kid and went great
your daughter was sexually assaulted and
she's got to get treatment as such she's
got to learn appropriate body touch
she's got to learn appropriate body
boundaries she's got to become safe in
her own skin
and she has to balance curiosity with
behavior
and she's going to need a professional
to walk her through them
i've got around like six different
waiting lists to see a counselor that's
great that's great
call back and say my daughter was
sexually abused and they'll probably
move you up
okay okay and okay you mom
have to stop carrying around that that's
your fault
okay
okay stop
it's not helping her get better it's not
undoing what happened and it's not true
stop
okay
okay i know i know it just loops and
loops and loops and loops
i'm like i like i told you i had
postpartum and um i had like emotionally
detached from having any more kids
because these two are already
i say such a handful but i mean any kids
at their age or a handful
and i had like just mentally
my husband had an appointment to get a
vasectomy and i've just been so stressed
out we lost our house a few months ago
so we've just kind of been couch hopping
and
all over the place and i've been so
stressed out that i didn't even realize
i was pregnant again so
oh ao so you got number three coming
yeah
i didn't even find out until i was
almost 16 weeks because i had been so
stressed out about trying to help her
hey i'm smiling
i'm sorry you are okay i'm smiling with
you because this baby's not coming into
the world in
um under a cloud of wish you weren't
here
and that's what i don't want to happen
nope then okay then we're going to make
that choice
right
yeah
here's what's got to happen in short
order you have a ton
of chaos a ton of trauma
if we sat down and talked about your
marriage you tell me you could
you got a lot going on you just lost
your house on top of it you've got a
child who's sexually assaulted that we
still got to deal with that you're
carrying around the burden of your
mother you're carrying around a lot
you can hear a lot
the epicenter of this starts with you
deciding you're worth being well
and you don't believe that
nothing on this trajectory changes until
you believe that because then when you
believe you're worth being well that
your marriage is worth being incredible
then you're worth changing your
financial situation and then you're
worth doing the work to heal from your
childhood stuff and then you're worth
filling the blank fill in the blank fill
in the plane
but it's timed today as i just told the
last caller tomorrow starts right now
if you want things to be different
tomorrow it starts right now
you
call those people back where your
daughter's on a waitlist tell her it was
sexual abuse involved
and also
you call somebody and get in today call
somebody and get in today hey listen
hang on the line i'm gonna send you a
copy of my book on your past change your
future and
um we're gonna hook you up with better
help counseling okay better help therapy
i want you to call them there's no
excuses you can see within 24 48 hours
and i'm going to pay for the first month
okay we're going to take care of it for
you but i want you to get on this asap
you're worth being well you got a lot
lot going on and by the way before i
hang up you decide today this is gonna
be a little wind no more yelling at my
kids period you're gonna make that
choice and when you find yourself
starting to yell you're gonna close your
mouth you're gonna walk out in the
backyard no more yelling i'm not giving
that to my mom anymore i'm not giving
that to my dad anymore i'm done
we're gonna start with that and we're
gonna have some small wins around no
more yelling or some small runs around
going to counseling some small ones
around taking care of my daughter and
we're gonna keep working on it and we're
gonna keep working on it we're gonna
keep working on it then we're gonna go
get well
we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they don't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john de loni show
listeners get 10 off their first month
so decide to invest in yourself you are
worth it and go to betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 percent off that's
betterhelp.com
all right hey we're back um
those last two calls were they got into
my soul a little bit uh
so
i'm following the uh the trend of the
internet since i went to my my cellular
device my phone
my little brother uh he sends me his
great memes all the time because he's
awesome at it and we'll put this meme up
on the youtube show but it makes me
happy
it's a picture
i guess you can customize wine bottle
labels now
which is
i had no idea that existed i'm going to
send some hilarious ones to my friends
but somebody put a picture of their
child and it's
called the most honest gift to a teacher
i've ever seen it's a bottle of wine
with a little
little kid's face and it just says the
label says our child might be the reason
you drink so enjoy the bottle on me
and that made me laugh inside my heart
and made my day a little bit better just
going to the internet and by the way he
sent me another one that said uh imagine
being rich enough that you don't have to
watch youtube videos every time
something breaks in your house
that one's not very funny is it no
you should edit that one out sarah that
one kind of sucks this is true
[Laughter]
oh and imagine the disappointment if a
wolf knew his descendant would be a pug
that's how your grandpa feels when he
sees your tight jeans i like that too
that one made me laugh
good job little brother scott you
brought me some joy
all right let's dive back in sarah just
edit that as you please some of those
were not great
all right let's go to amy in los angeles
ca what's up amy city of angels how are
we doing
good morning how you doing today dr john
we're figuring it out figuring it out
what's up
same here
that's why i called you
so the initial question was
my husband bet
and
well i know you don't promote divorce
but
at this point i just feel unsafe stuck
and to be honest i just don't trust him
anymore okay tell me about it
he bet does he have a um addiction
yes
and so what's he put your family through
thank god we don't have kids so it's
just me and him
but it just has been a lot of
emotions hiding
lying of course
what's the financial damage
uh
with debt and that probably up to the
100 thousands now that he's gambled away
yeah so he got out of hand for sure
yeah so
i will tell you this um i'm not a like
you said i don't condone divorce there's
absolutely some some some situations
that people need to run for the hills
what i don't do
99.9 of the time is i don't tell people
you need to get divorced that's a
personal decision that somebody's got to
come to
and
for you to start the call that way
with the words i'm unsafe
my husband's burned through a hundred
thousand dollars of our household income
how long have you all been married
five years
in five years how old are you
i'm 35. okay
for you to call with those challenges
laid out and to say i
i'm down the road on divorce that sounds
like you're already there so is that
where you are
yeah i already looked into
the paperwork and what do i have to do
because i don't want this to keep
affecting me on the long run
so i would rather
cut it right now where he's to be nice
of course he's
ashamed and
sorry and cried to me every night
and sometimes i think about it you know
to be like he's a good man i'm not
excusing him
has he gone to get help has he gone to
treat him no okay i i ask him many times
and
he i feel like he doesn't think he has a
problem
but with all of this
evidence and
years of doing it and getting the same
outcome
so of course
it's a problem now it's an addiction
yeah and
um i will often give people grace on
their addiction
um
where i hold the line is when somebody
says um i refuse to
go seek wellness and seek healing that's
what i'll say that's the choice so
someone could say hey i can't control
this behavior it's out of control great
you can control whether you go seek
connection and support and healing and
um he's not made that choice two
important things for you to note this
has nothing to do with you
and that can that should be
good because often you can feel like i'm
not enough what is it about me that he
that this is more important that's not
how that works is that where you are
yeah because um it's so fun to help
people it's like oh we just have a kid
he would change i just want to bring a
kid
he's like are you serious exactly that
mentality
no i'm not going to be part of that he
needs to heal first
if there was a chance we need to heal
our marriage which at this point known
but i have done everything in my power
to help him and
yeah i feel like i was not enough for
him to stop that i need to bring another
leg
to the picture here no no that's not a
don't don't go down that road
no i won't
the road to go down is this
you can control two things in the world
yeah the thoughts you let circulate in
your mind that you meditate on and you
spend time on and your actions that's it
with a period you can't heal him you
can't do some
new thing that he's going to be like oh
i didn't think about that i'm going to
go make this he can't do that right
and i don't take it away from him i'm
i'm call me what you will when it comes
to addiction man um but from people who
are workaholics to urnaholics to
alcoholics and everyone in between
i have a real soft spot in my head for
people who struggle with addiction i
really do i have a soft spot in my heart
i get it
and
when you make somebody unsafe you force
them
into making hard relational choices
because you won't
and that's where you find yourself
you're not safe
and so i'm not going to tell you to
leave him i'm going to tell you that you
can only control you
and that you're worth being well and
you're worth being safe
okay yes
i believe it
and
even the right decision here
is gonna be painful the choice to stay
and to work it out and to yell and
scream and demand he go to treatment
is gonna be painful the choice to leave
and get divorced it's going to be
painful
and so when you hurt in the next month
two months five months seven months nine
months
the evidence of i mean the the feeling
of hurt is not evidence that you're
making the wrong decision
you don't have a way out of this it's
not going to be painful
okay
you have to decide i'm worth being well
and i'm worth being safe and
at this point my husband is not is
choosing to not go do the things that he
needs to do to be well
and i'm so heartbroken for you amy i'm
so sorry
thank you
i really wanted to make it work to be
honest
of course of course
of course have you ever have you given
him the or what statement have you said
this is the line
okay i've been fi five years married
seven in a relationship
and that's the thing like i saw the red
flag since the beginning and but i guess
when you are in love
you lose track of those five senses or
sixth sense
and the fantasy the fantasy is so strong
yeah it's beautiful were you um were you
had you been married before or were you
single until you were 30
no i was married before okay all right
so this was going to be my 23rd
this is going to be the one huh
yeah of course he was do you have some
shame in your heart and mind that
it didn't work out again for a second
time no to be honest no i'd rather
that's away
i'd rather step away and find my
well-being that stay in a relationship
that's just not working well it's less
about
again it's less about just not working
and more
you are unsafe
and the dishonesty and the hey we're one
bad evening away from being homeless and
foodless and retirementless
this is you out on the plank and you are
waving in the wind here this is a scary
scary place
and your husband's struggling man he's
sick and he needs to go get healing and
my heart breaks for him heartbreak's for
you guys marks for your marriage but
you're worth being well
and i'm so
i'm sorry about this this this one's uh
this one sucks too man all right we'll
be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndaloni.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right we are back
let me just say this
this show today was hard and it wasn't
hard in a
what i would call an acute way
like
um we didn't hear a mom who's just lost
a two-year-old or somebody who's
considering suicide right
today's show felt hard because
it's life
like
we all make dumb decisions because
somebody says
hey i'll love you we've all made
um
found ourselves
replaying stories and narratives and
scripts that our parents gave us and old
coaches gave us and crappy uncles gave
us
and we
hate ourselves for continuing the cycles
that we see emerge
when i hear things come out of my mouth
and i'm like i know exactly where that
came from and i see my son's
face the look on his face and i remember
feeling that face
or we find ourselves in relationships
and we come to the edge of our boundary
and we say i can go no more i can no
longer be unsafe
what did i do
and that haunting
am i this powerless what if i just love
differently what if i just loved more
right this show is
a more realistic picture i think than
most shows in that this is the ugly
messiness of life
and life's hard and so
something that will remind all three of
these folks off air that
i want to remind you guys
don't do life alone
get people with you and listen listen to
people upstream middle of stream when
they're pulling you out of the stream
life's hard life's hard life's hard
surround yourself with people who love
you who've got your back who will walk
alongside you when things get messy and
hopefully
when you're about to step on the
rattlesnake they can grab your hand and
go whoa whoa whoa whoa look
and you can go yeah i want to step there
but it's not going to be wise
as we wrap up today's show
man this is one of my favorite songs
ever one of my favorite songs of all
time all time
it's the john mayer
man this is a deep cut but it's so good
the song's called the age of worry and
it goes like this
close your eyes and clone yourself and
build your heart and army to defend your
innocence while you do everything wrong
don't be scared to walk alone don't be
scared to like it there's no time that
you must be home so sleep where darkness
falls
alive in the age of worry smile in the
age of worry go wild in the age of worry
say worry why should i care
know your fights not with them yours is
with your time here dream your dreams
but don't pretend make friends with what
you are
give your heart then change your mind
you're allowed to do it
be alive in the age of worry and say
worry
why should i care
we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode what did
your brother do he has a couple of
charges that have to do with a minor so
have you sat down with that and just sat
in it for a second that's hard
it is
i've tried to i want you to write your
brother a letter that you're never going
to send him okay i'm showing up every
day i'm putting my best foot forward i'm
doing my masters and then at the end of
the lesson the kids literally don't care
at all how do you know when it's time to
leave here's my
here's the story i tell myself i don't
run from things anymore i go two things
and one thing that i definitely notice
about myself is the pattern that i
seem to always cheat on every
relationship that i'm on you're pretty
lonely guy is that fair
yeah and so loneliness
exacerbates what you're experiencing